Espera que miles de personas vuelvan a
salir a las calles de Francia y las
fuerzas policiales están en alerta
máxima en ese mercado de tu luz las
opiniones están divididas sobre si la
batalla contra la reforma de las
pensiones aún vale la pena para mí está
hecho se acabó
bajo el presidente shurak no hubo una
ley que se votó y luego le dimos marcha
atrás
cerca de 250 diferentes movilizaciones
esperan alrededor del país en la que es
la jornada número 14 contra la reforma
pensional que ya fue aprobada pero el
gobierno se mantiene en firme y no
muestra signos de retroceder el 4 de
junio publicó los dos primeros decretos
para su implementación sin embargo eso
no ha sido suficiente para desalentar a
los sindicatos y los partidos de
oposición dicen que están a tiempo para
revertir la legislación vamos a echar un
vistazo a los 31 decretos y Tan pronto
como identifiquemos el más mínimo
defecto legal lo atacaremos la
responsabilidad recae en el gobierno que
está implementando a la fuerza una
reforma la voluntad de la mayoría de los
franceses
Mientras tanto el parlamento se está
preparando para examinar un artículo que
por medio de una enmienda Busca que la
edad de jubilación vuelva a ser los 62
años y no los 64 que formuló la reforma
y que fue avalado por el consejo
constitucional una iniciativa presentada
por un pequeño grupo independiente de
parlamentarios respaldados por partidos
de oposición pero el presidente de la
asamblea nacional ya amenazó con
declarar la inelegible para revisión